bruno margolle merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors au sommet
européen emmanuel macron à 600 soutien
aux pêcheurs
est-ce que cela vous redonne confiance
pour la suite oui bonsoir oui et bien
sûr le fait que comment le le président
de la république affiche comment son
soutien à la pêche et je l'en remercie
d'ailleurs c'est une bonne chose et puis
que les les négociations se poursuivent
tant qu'elle se poursuive il ya de
l'espoir
alors l'union européenne est prête à
faire un effort raisonnable sur la
question de la pêche l'un des principaux
points de blocage dans les négociations
sur sa relation post briques site avec
le royaume uni est c'est ce qu'a indiqué
le négociateur européen michel barnier
est ce que la france peut se retrouver
seul sur ce dossier
elle a beaucoup à perdre bien entendu
que la france je pense que vis-à-vis des
27 c'est c'est le pays qu'il est
certainement le plus impacté vis-à-vis
des autres il faut il faut
impérativement que l'on reste soudée il
y a eu comme un groupe du haut et fort
les les huit pays les plus concernés par
la pêche britannique les eaux
britanniques
il faut surtout pas que l'on que l'on se
dise où il faut garder l'unité de
manière à pouvoir continuer il faudrait
pas que la pêche soit vraiment la
variable d'ajustement
et voilà je remercie michel barnier de
tenir bon et nous avons entièrement
confiance jusqu'à la fin alors le droit
de la mer place le
le royaume uni en position de force
qu'est ce que vous proposez vous
aujourd'hui en tant que pêcheur à
nouveau bien entendu nous demandons un
statu quo de continuer à pêcher comme on
le faisait 1
personnellement ça fait 40 ans que je
travaille dans dans les eaux
britanniques je vois pas pourquoi faire
on me retirer ce droit
du jour au lendemain j'ai rien demandé
moi j'ai pas demandé à ce que le bris
des britanniques sorte de l'union
européenne
quelles que soient les raisons donc
aujourd'hui je demande tout simplement
enfin nous demandons tout simplement à
continuer à travailler dans les eaux
britanniques comme nous le faisons parce
que les eaux britanniques on peut le
dire sont des zones très poissonneuses
et c'est clair que si on prend la manche
c'est quand même un endroit très c'est
un entonnoir donc c'est le poisson
pasche passe dans dans cet entonnoir est
bon il n'a pas de limites qui passe du
côté anglais du côté français le but du
pêcheur c'est de chercher poisson et le
poisson n'a pas dé n'a pas de limites
bien entendu il passe suivant les cours
en suivant les marais suivant le vent
est sûr qu'il passait selon les saisons
il passe d'un côté plus d'un côté de
l'autre
aujourd'hui même les coteaux qui nous
sont attribués ça ne veut plus rien dire
parce que si on peut plus aller dans les
eaux britanniques pour pour les péchés
ça n'a plus aucun sens
très concrètement quelles répercussions
cela pourrait avoir pour vous pêcheurs
pour tous les pêcheurs de ne plus
pouvoir se rendre dans ces eaux
britanniques
la grosse problématique c'est que il va
la ligne médiane qui sépare la manche
comment tous les bat tout le fin mot à
dire tous les états membres tous les
bateaux les hollandais et les belges
les irlandais qui pêchent dans la manche
aujourd'hui ils vont tous se rabattre
bien entendu sur la côte française du
côté français il va y avoir des gros
problèmes de cohabitation de
surexploitation
honnêtement ça va être un très très très
compliqué un impact également pour les
conservateurs bien sûr un impact très
certainement bien sûr parce que le si je
prends la place boulonnaise
qui hélas des centres européens les plus
importants qui traite plus de 300 mille
tonnes de boisson qui vient
essentiellement de l'ecosse 20 ça ça et
ça risque d'être compliqué pour avoir la
matière première bien entendu donc
commencé que les anglais consomme que 20
% de ce qui pêche les autres 80% ses
exports s'est exporté essentiellement en
europe même la france beaucoup la france
donc je pense que de ce côté là ils ont
beaucoup à perdre alors dans le plan de
relance européen il a été prévu de
réserver un fonds de 5 milliards d'euros
pour couvrir les dégâts commerciaux et
humains justement du bric site
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de
votre côté aujourd'hui cette enveloppe
là je ne sais pas exactement à quoi elle
correspond un n'y a pas que la pêche
bien entendu il ya tout un tas
d'économies qui sont dépendants de
l'union europe de l'est des îles
britanniques
mais aujourd'hui c'est 5 millions de ces
5 milliards d'euros l'an est ce que
c'est prévu pour en attendant de trouver
des accords parce que je suppose que
même si on arrive sur un odile qu'il y
aura des accords de quelque façon et on
sait pertinement que ça ne sera plus
jamais comme avant même si on trouve des
accords donc il va falloir patienter
plusieurs mois voire un an j'en sais
rien et pendant cette année là il va
bien falloir continuer à travailler dans
des conditions respectables et éviter de
perdre tous nos d'entreprise à terre
comme en mer
parce que un au deal ça signifierait que
beaucoup d'entreprises seraient beaucoup
d'entreprises de marins pêcheurs
seraient obligés de fermer la porte
bien entendu il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises en l'occurrence les
bateaux qui font la pêche au large sur
boulogne lice aux indépendants à 100 %
des hommes britanniques
si on prend les chalutiers aussi bien
les chalutiers les pilleurs de long va
dire qu'ils sont inféodés à la manche
unipêche on va dire entre 40 50 % de
leur production du côté britannique
donc ça va c'est indéniablement on va
perdre une bonne partie de la flottille
européenne je parle pas que de la france
mais européenne également merci beaucoup
bruno margolle pour votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes pêcheurs
président de la fédé au passé la
fédération des organisations de
producteurs de la pêche artisanale